hello welcome to codetech tutorials okay
an update on the quitting reference from
the video a couple days ago where i said
i quit
and i do quit some things i wasn't
really that specific in the video and
yes everyone got the impression that i
was completely quitting youtube but
really i'm more like quitting trying so
hard i'm quitting putting in so much
effort as
i explained it's basically a huge drain
on me and not really any any benefit in
particular this might be a good thing
because i'll be probably producing more
videos as they'll be a lot easier to
produce in general if i'm not having to
research edit b-roll re-record
the whole nine yards of trying to make a
proper video basically there's also some
other things i'm going to quit and that
is basically being a
tech support in the comments there's a
lot of people who ask questions and
sometimes they think oh your video is
wrong and i read it and and i know the
answer and i try to explain and usually
it helps them i'm gonna have to stop
doing that it's a lot of additional
effort and generally the person asking
the question
can figure it out for themselves or
other people can help them this is
usually really simple stuff
in general but naturally a lot of people
come to my channel to learn and
sometimes the things that a lot of us
take for granted newer coders haven't
figured out yet so it's just part of the
learning curve one of the great things
about video form is they can just be
re-watched and there are old ones for
previous context i know that takes a lot
of time so i don't expect everyone to do
it but the point is i can't be tech
support in the comments
like i have been in some cases
especially for really obscure errors i'm
going to reserve that for the discord
and for people who have joined the
channel
through the membership and patrons too
while the patrons still going oops i
guess i just kind of made an
announcement i am going to collapse the
patron into just youtube there's really
no point in having a redundant system
the join button on youtube is exactly
the same and it's one less thing i have
to log into an update and i can make
videos or posts that are for members
only that automatically work correctly
whereas with patreon i have to like
unlist them and copy it or make them
private and allow certain emails access
only it's really complicated and
annoying to post videos on youtube for
patrons only so that's another thing
that's gonna happen i'm not exactly sure
when
but definitely before the end of the
year so yeah that's what i meant by
quitting although in all your guys's
defense
when i made that video i was seriously
considering fully quitting and so i kind
of toned it that way because i was
pretty sure i was but i sat on that
video for about three days and
re-watched a couple times to make sure i
wanted to put it out and i basically
decided that i'm quitting aspects of
youtube and this whole thing and not
quitting as an entirely disappearing
type thing i'm not ready to go full
mountain man in the mountains yet that's
a redundant statement mountain man in
the mountains i read every single
comment from the video that i am
quitting video
and a lot of you were really really
supportive
and it really surprised me i really
thought that video was going to tank and
people were just going to unsubscribe
and say whatever or
but there was a lot of support and i
really appreciate that that means so
much to me you guys also had a lot of
really good ideas
about how to handle things and i might
implement some of that in the future but
also i'm trying to be a little bit
minimalistic
i also still want to do youtube but what
was happening was i was just spending so
much time messing with videos and
youtube sometimes that it was really
burning me out and making me
dislike this all together so i have to
take a healthier approach and i think
that healthier approach is
more
raw videos
they're still going to be edited i don't
think there will ever be a time where i
completely don't edit a video at all
because there are some basic things i
can do that at least make it more
watchable and not so boring but all the
creative edits probably have to go
because those are by far the most time
consuming i know that they probably give
videos a big part of the the interest
and watchability and all that and that's
just something i'm gonna have to
sacrifice it does still stand that if i
do reach enough momentum and get to a
level where i can start editing videos
in a more creative manner again i would
absolutely love to i also still do
intend on getting a
more normal job at some point i'm not
really doing that urgently
because well quite frankly i don't want
one i've had some great experiences in
the past but i've also been through a
lot of misery with a lot of jobs i've
had in the past too and i have learned a
lot and i feel like there's no need for
me to go back and relearn the same
lessons that i already learned from
taking corporate jobs
really the only things i would probably
take are c plus developer jobs or
something in a game development studio i
get offers pretty much daily
from recruiters to interview at places
for all sorts of service desk and
desktop support and those are a hard no
i don't think even for a million dollars
a year i would work a service desk again
that was one of the most miserable times
of my life and my health suffered for it
i recall having chest pains at times and
i thought that i was going to have a
heart attack
or something along those lines i'm not
sure but there's no amount of money
that's worth and
that's what being at a service desk was
basically doing to me so
yeah there's really no amount that could
give me to go back to something like
that and to further expand on that
i don't think it was just me the
sentiment of how stressful it was was
shared by everybody there and i've heard
it across organizations pretty much
everywhere
anyway
that's all i wanted to say and keep you
guys updated hit the like and sub button
if you want to see more from me i will
still be producing content to be clear
and i could use your help
and
all that so hit the join button here on
youtube it would mean a lot keep coding
you guys see the next one peace out oh
one last thing and i guess this would be
an incentive to actually join i did two
previous takes of this video that i'm
not going to use because well
i probably said some things that i
shouldn't have said but
i stand by my word i just don't think
they should necessarily be public but if
you join i'll make them available to
members so you can see and hear more of
my opinion and reasoning if you like
alright thanks guys peace
you